minicar michelino bongiorno
[Musica]
solita storia
inah piccolino arrivate segnerà il suo
nome non avete visto il video precedente
in cui vi raccontiamo come l'abbiamo
presa e la sua storia andate a vederlo e
grazie mille per tutti i consigli del
mio vero ci avete dato un sacco di idee
con rinomina ora prepariamo i biglietti
mi sceglierà il suono
eccoci qua stiamo leggendo tutti i
vostri commenti grazie mille per averci
lasciato cosi tanti consigli per i nomi
iniziamo per un momento perché io che mi
avete scritto ovviamente purtroppo non
potrò scrivere tutti i nomi che mi avete
consigliato perché migliaia ci sono 1400
commenti ha detto quindi noi seguiremo
sono alcuni allora uno che mi è piaciuto
un sacco e trottola o trottola perché
avremo un pochettino quindi sembra un po
una trottola e anche quel problemino la
zampetta poverina quindi sembra un po
una trottola quindi un nome troppo poi
scegliamo di un altro un altro nome
super carino e divertente che ci avete
consigliato è
zucchina
abbiamo contro feltri di scriviamo anche
zucchine chi mi fa troppo ridere come no
segreto questa avventura aggiunge
un'esploratrice
[Musica]
poi un altro nome che ci avete scritto
in tantissimi e mi chiamo ha quindi
scriviamo anche mia che sembra tipo la
premiazione di mia poco altro nome ci
sono poi vediamo
un altro nome che c'è perché scritte in
tantissimi mi è l'una e arriviamo anche
un altro nome che ho visto tanto e
nuvola nuvola dei
nove che mi è piaciuto un sacco siccome
che io ho raccontato la sua storia mi ha
detto che lei è una guerriera fortissima
mi avete consigliato athena la dea
quindi
e dove è finita la gattina sta
esplorando la predica
piccolina non sta mai ferma vuole
lavorare tutto
[Musica]
che abbiamo già un bel po di nomi
questi sono quelli che ci hanno colpito
oppure quelli più votati che ci sono
piaciuti ma ovviamente ce ne sono
tantissimi altri che ci sono piaciuti
che ci avete consigliato ma non possiamo
scriverli tutti adesso però scrivo un
nome a cui ho pensato io e quando l'ho
vista mi ha fatto subito pensare a
questo nome però non ve lo dico sarà una
sorpresa e lo scoprirete solamente se
lei sceglierà il bigliettino con quel
nome
dai che vedevo le quali però non te lo
dicono dai almeno a me dirlo no no
perché non lo diciamo anche tu dovrei
scrivere il naso anch'io e ti fidi dei
nomi che tu io sicuramente sarà un nome
con un qualcosa di cibo
potrebbe essere lo sai
[Musica]
e ora vitale deve scrivere il nome che
lui vorrebbe fare la cartina spremono
scelga questo nome però è altrimenti
detto che farà
sì che
il comparto che lo guardare e tu che fai
che fai laggiù sotto al letto sta
provando a suonare la tastiera
già fatto dopo andare però è lodevole
tagliare prima
e nel frattempo che vitale prepara i
nomi mi è venuta un'idea come pratica
una gattina se le faccio vedere il
pupazzo gigante diminu la gattina
vediamo come reagirei se non avete
ancora lasciato un bip iace mi
raccomando lasciato in me piaceva se
questo video raggiunti 7.000 vi piace ci
sarà un altro video con la gattina ecco
qua il pupazzo gigante diminu vediamo
come reagirà
è piccolina questa
forse non l'ha vista riguarda
[Musica]
siano identiche cicchetti qua
guarda e un gatto come te
ma gliene frega niente
guardate quante grado il pupazzo in
confronto a lei che è bricoli stival
ecco qua tutti i biglietti con i nomi io
appoggero i biglietti a terra e
metteremo a fianco un croccantino il
nome da quelle andrà vorrà dire che sarà
il nome che lei sceglie se non mi piace
è il nome deve piacere a lei e non a te
ok va bene mi sembra giusto però questa
volta faremo tre round lingue si tre
round sceglierà un nome più di una volta
vuol dire che il nome prescelto brandi
via
ancora posizione i croccantini e
nota che arrivando recapito per
spiegarvi arrivando la piccolina non
sapevo
mi chiamo quale sceglie
sembra stava per scendere a quello ma ma
decisa vediamo vediamo
quasi segnerà
non l'ho mangiato dobbiamo vedere quale
a mangia e li stava dorando tutti
ma controllando tutti i nuovi quello ha
provato ad assaggiarlo palace fu dato
a cannes esce gli capita che piace
quello deve controllarli tutti ei no non
piace nessuno di questi ma scavo vero
zemin istruttore segno una crocchetta
come non ha molta fame perché ha
mangiato tantissimo prendiamo i nomi
delle crocchette che ha toccato per
prime quindi la prima che ha toccate
questa tecnica è quella vediamo che non
è
ma guarda ovviamente dove stanno le cose
e mi sono poi pratese e una furbona è
andata alle buste delle crocchette di
ceo crocchette
evitiamo una vuole andare verso di voi
quindi prendiamola come primo round
prendiamo la prima crocchetta che ha
toccato e la prima è
zucchina
a troppo io e questo nome assetto
zucchina come primo nome ancora ci
mancano altri due era un hockey orari
mischiamo to see nome
schiavo rischiamo in i piccoletti
vediamo si sta avvicinando vitiano quale
sceglierà
ok facciamolo a tornare qua con il suo
giochino preferito il topino rota
oro tutto ciò che lo breve
non mi dispiace per quello che adesso si
è arrabbiata non viene ancora qua
vediamo che non le serie
nome
molto decisa abbiamo preferito andare
tutto a letto
eccolo finalmente
forse sta mangiando la crocchetta
vediamo ha scelto quella
accettando con la cassetta del nome
diciamo che nome è andata a scegliermi
un altro ha detto
in nome
dei nomi che ho scelto io
manca ancora un altro round vediamo che
non mi sceglierà per il prossimo round
degli schiavi uomini una mamma mia siamo
orgogliosi
che ha
già pronta
e molto incuriosita attenta
si è proprio lì per scappare sente
rumore dei foglietti
ha
appoggiato la proprietà
questo la zappa
su questo
ma proprio scelto quello
mettiamo che cos'altro fa
ha assunto anche quello
mi faccio dico tutti allora vediamo ha
scelto questi 26 tra questi due
foglietti c'è un nome già scelto sarà il
suo nome vediamo primo foglietto
athena che mi piace non mi piace
secondo foglietta
[Musica]
antolini
provata che c è si una maga e anche
berlino è un mago meraviglio che no non
ero uno magari un vago
voglio sapere qual è il nome che avevi
scelto tu
perché assenza evitare
non lo so se buona idea ma che
sicuramente sarà divertente qui abbiamo
luna
qui abbiamo mia
questo è un esempio un capitolo è quello
che scelta io 38 la lite arrivando
zucchi va
qui abbiamo nuvola e quindi messapi per
ultimo quello che ho scelto io ho scelto
perché mi fa pensare a lei questo questo
nome
si pone
perché ora cipolletta la donna
ha fatto per fortuna non la scelta
perché effettivamente cipolletta come
ore cipolletta
mesi stanno trovando comune ci bombetta
grazie tante per tutti i nomi che ci
avete consigliato erano tutti bellissimi
vero ma chi vuol essere subito il tiro
è sempre mi piace per vedere altri video
con la piccola di no se non avete visto
il video di ieri e cliccate in una di
queste quattro candeline per vederlo e
ora mi lasciava quattro case linee su
cui vi carfalo dei nostri altri video
clicca questo quello che preferite